thank you thank you everyone I really
appreciate you being here today uh I
realize that lunch is also going on and
this is amazing that anyone is here
right now when lunch comes out uh so
thank you so much for for taking your
time to be with us uh we're going to
talk about blocks what I think is a very
cool concept uh that can help make your
life better when you're making
um
different coding programs projects with
python all right so uh I'm Jeff Hale I'm
a developer Advocate at prefect and
despite what I'm wearing right now I'm
often into Hawaiian shirts uh so if you
see somebody around that might be me uh
Lincoln Outdoors playing ultimate
frisbee
and haven't chat about any of those
things if you'd like to talk I do a lot
of writing and teaching about python so
often medium if you've hang out there
you might see some things I write and I
also organize events I'm a co-organizer
of the data science DC Meetup anybody
here from DC area
yeah apple DC folks awesome awesome
um check out what we got going on in DC
so I'm a big fan of prefect not just
because they they pay my paycheck but
also because they actually make it much
easier to deal with a lot of common pain
points and really solve those in an
elegant way
it's an open source library and has a
growing company behind it
it's it's a python python library to
clear
and when people ask why why should I use
this like why should I be here talking
about prefects often I say it's about
coordinating your data flows anybody
here use prefect
before purple hands okay a little a
little back and forth okay right on
um it gives you observation and
orchestration that's like a big awesome
awesome pitch we'll talk a little bit
about that but that's not the main
thrust of our talk here today uh we are
going to talk about blocks and so
there's a few Concepts that are useful
to know you just might hear Us slip into
how about using flow and task decorators
if you've used uh prefect before you
know those are kind of a way to take a
function and add some magic to it as
some in a good way that's a pretty big
magic to it
uh and then when you want to really
productionize things you can turn it
into a deployment
just takes a couple of steps but then
something that you can use as a server
and then you can share things across a
workspace with your other users
so those are a few terms we might use
today we're all about blocks
so why why might you want to use these
blocks well it can make collaboration
easier that's one of our big big nice
selling points of using blocks you can
cut down on your errors when you're
trying to configure things and give you
some increased security over a lot of
methods we'll talk about that a bit
uh and much easier extendability this
kind of builds in an API interface that
makes it easier to not you know have so
you don't have to actually Fork uh Fork
the code and the repo and go from there
instead you can just kind of have a nice
way to extend it very very simply and in
the end hopefully save you a bunch of
time right that's like our goal here
make our life easier have a better
experience save some time
all right so so what are these blocks
things well at the end of the day
they're just python objects like
everything else in Python right but they
do have a couple of special features
they do have a little bit of front end
uh Magic that is really nice and they
work on a server so you can use them in
different places so we'll talk about
options there and then um python is free
opens or sorry prefix is a free open
source library but we do have if you
want Enterprise features we'll let you
pay us for that uh and we have some
access controls at those levels
so these blocks these objects are stored
in server side uh in either our open
source Orion database that ships right
when you get prefect
sqlite database by default but if you
want to go to postgres that's fine you
can do that or we can manage things and
host them for you in our Cloud so you
don't have to worry about that
so blocks give you a bunch of choices
that's going to be one one theme Here
at risk of doing something I try never
to do I will read this out because it's
right at that 25 word cutoff
data practitioners have historically
been forced to choose between the simple
setup experience of low code data
integration tools and the flexibility of
an all python pipeline often it's just
one or the other right you get a simple
form fill some stuff out now you can
connect to it right you've seen that
before uh or it's like here's a blank
slate here's some python
go figure it out right just do it all
yourself
so as the meme says why don't we just do
both
prefect blocks is the solution to that
problem
and and maybe the only mullet reference
of the day uh you can think of prefect
blocks like a Mullen
structured form in the front
nice and easy flexible let that hair
flow in the back
flexible python code
so these blocks you can think of as low
code connectors that actually have a
first class python experience get the
best of both worlds
so you're probably thinking right now
this is really cool how can I get one of
these
well
if you use the python package manager if
install prefect good to go
make sure you have prefect version two
here we built version one learned a lot
of things along the way blocks come in
in version two which we just released
this summer the general availability
all right so you actually want to make a
block here how are you going to do it
said you can make it with a nice form
you can be in the UI just click on the
little add button here say you want to
make a secret block you'll see there's a
bunch of types
fill up a little form
that's all you need to do
give it a name and a value hit create
and then we give you a little code
snippet that you can use in your code to
use that block to use that and get that
value it's as simple as importing the
class
loading at uh that block you made and
then actually accessing the value
and you notice that those are the value
is obscured here obfuscated
in the in the bottom that's a little bit
of security feature we have so you just
don't have that sitting out on your left
it's a nice way to make things a little
safer
so that's option one use a form option
two you're like I don't want to use a UI
no I'm a coder because I'm a coder okay
great that's fine you can just create
with code it's just a class right this
is this block type is a secret class so
you can import it
create an object of it
and then save it
and then there you go it's in your UI
you can use it right there you got the
same little code snippet and use it in
your code
it's all it's pretty seamless feels
pretty magical
so you got flexible creation and in
flexible editing there's a little edit
drop down there too in the UI if you
want to do that
so that's that's a nice a nice situation
so let's talk about like an actual use
case now all right so we talked about
Secrets a little bit say you actually
want to share some provider
configuration this is something most of
us have to do at one time or another if
you're collaborating with other folks
right
so if you want to figure out like how
should I say how should I share this
information how should I do this
option one you could just like hard code
that right in there I'm not gonna ask
for a show of hands we've we've probably
all been there at one point
um but you don't want to right I mean
Bitcoin prices are down to like 16 000
earlier today maybe it's 12 000 now I
don't know but there's still enough
money out there that you don't want
someone using your AWS compute to go
mine some Bitcoin and let's that's a bad
situation so just don't hard code it you
don't want it getting in in there some
way
you could use environment variables
environment variables are a pretty
common solution to this problem and um
they work pretty well but they do have
some shortcomings they're often kind of
viewable in logs and things like that
they're tied to your machine right so
you gotta like get them get them out
there another way so it it does take a
little bit of work
third option
you can use a Secrets manager right big
cloud providers have these
but then you're tied to that provider a
lot of times takes a little bit of work
to
to do that oftentimes if you're using a
something like a custom solution it's
already there that's Works across Cloud
providers there's a decent sized
learning curve on
um and then you don't get all these
configuration benefits right it's just
like there's a secret there
so you might think hey uh this sounds
pretty cool just like build this myself
right we we're all hackers we want to go
build things so you can build a custom
Secrets manager that sounds like a fun
thing to you
then you are not me
uh you have to add some configuration
you got to think about encryption if you
want to have this on a server to use
with other people you got to think about
syncing that it's gonna take a lot of
code and a lot of work right uh it's not
not something I I would personally want
to play with
so prefect blocks I offer is a solution
to this there are again obfuscated with
pedantics secret string right out of the
gate
uh they're encrypted at rest in the
database and you can use hash record
Vault or something like that if you
really want to we have a integration
that our partners at Intel made and
we'll talk about how you can extend
blocks in a lot of ways just
all right
you're with me
awesome we're gonna take a little detour
now this little historical context
little fun time I bet you didn't think
you're gonna get a history lesson here
today but you are so
um Charles Babbage who sort of Charles a
couple hands yeah maybe like somewhere
uh I I think there should be like some
documentaries and books about him I'm
sure there's some stuff out there but
it's wild uh in working on reading up
for this I learned a little bit this
dude was super duper smart right
mathematician in the late early 1800s
um he was a philosopher code breaker
during a war he was like breaking
ciphers in 1850. sounds pretty cool like
no computers around right
uh he was an inventor and invented such
fun things as the
optomos go probably butchering that
right uh didn't actually get it made in
his lifetime but this is a common
pattern he designed a lot of really cool
things he's got the cow catcher there
like big range you know all over the
place uh very useful stuff
um and He Made A Difference Engine which
is something maybe folks have heard of
kind of taking some ideas from a loom
and and how to like add some automation
there
started getting that produced a little
bit never had one fully made and then
iterated on that to make the analytical
or to design the analytical engine
again never actually completed but
pretty amazing like we were Forerunner
of the modern computer it had branching
it had looping possibilities it was at
least considered to be potentially
touring complete uh according to
something I read so uh we'll see it was
never built so
um but pretty wild uh and this is
actually this is just a piece a picture
of a part of it they're actually
multiple pieces together
and it used the idea of Punch Cards this
is not a punch card from the 1800s this
is from the 1970s I think my father uh
might have used Punch Cards I won't ask
anyone here if they've used SpongeBob
cards before but pretty revolutionary
the back then uh this idea was already
being put into motion
uh and you might have heard of Ada
Lovelace she's been getting a lot of
good press lately uh she was kind of
wrote the first computer program is
attributed is doing that for babbage's
analytical engine
even though the thing didn't exist she
wrote a program for it and like figured
out how to do that like
that's mind-blowing right like totally
just totally wild to me
all right fast forward 1991.
great white and Rossum introduces Python
and releases it to the world who's
working on it in the late 80s uh
hopefully you've at least a little
familiar with python you're here at a pi
data conference so I'm guessing you
might might have might have used it a
little bit
um and I know about you but it was
something that really was the first
language I found that I was like ah yes
I like this this makes sense and I feel
like it's something I can build with uh
so huge huge kudos to everyone who's
worked in the python ecosystem and
helped make language what it is today
all right so fast forward again 2018.
stream what's on the scene oh here's
who's streamlit
maybe a third a quarter okay cool uh
this is just a little example of a
streamlit app this is the the front end
here that I made that shows how to uh
use visualization libraries and kind of
how you can interact with them and also
shows the code that goes along with them
and the point here is that you can write
in Python make the whole thing in Python
and you don't have to think about the
front-end JavaScript HTML CSS any of
that stuff
you get that front end for free
it's pretty awesome I'm a big
man so uh this
makes it so that as a python developer
you do not need to think about having
the skill set to do those front-end type
things
it's it's very nice and it's useful for
data apps and play them into
websites
also in 2018
Jeremiah lowen
gives a talk at Pi data DC anybody at Pi
data DC in 2018
wow that's awesome all over faces here I
was there and it was super fun
um and Jeremiah gave a talk called task
failed successfully where it kind of
introduced prefect and the workflow
orchestration idea behind it
and then 2019 prefect one actually comes
out for General availability in the
spring 2022
we did a whole rewrite reduce release
that to General availability just about
four months ago and this is what
actually includes some blocks here
so with prefect 2
we've got blocks that allow python
developers to build this HTML interface
pretty easily so similar you don't have
to think about making that form you saw
right it's just like there
ships right away
but it's different than Streamlight and
that streamlin's really targeting a
front end
like web app kind of environment here
whereas prefect blocks are really trying
to get your configuration in so you can
use those then in the back end on your
code so different purposes but same idea
of like lowering the barriers where you
don't need to know about these other
languages
okay
thank you for the little journey down
history land there hope you enjoyed that
uh let's talk about block types now
so there are a whole bunch of different
types of blocks that prefect ships with
right out of the gate
we've got strings date times Json
options you got a secret that we saw
those things are available right away
for you
but then there are other things and
there's still blocks but there's
specialized for different use cases so
if you want to store your store your
code somewhere to run and the prefect
kind of world you can do that on GitHub
or any of the major Cloud providers here
put in AWS and S3 Azure just yes
whatever you want to do other remote
storage you can make a block for that
those are just there before you're ready
to use and you don't have to think about
like what are all the things I need to
make this connect you saw you have a
form that makes it easy
if you want to run your code in certain
infrastructure Docker kubernetes
whatever it is uh those those are
available right out of the gate and then
there's other options
that are extendable too
if you want to get notifications when
something doesn't work how you want it
to in your code you can get those use
blocks for that also notification block
types like email
I mean I know it's like the kids aren't
doing it these days but like maybe most
of the folks in this room are still
using some email uh we got slack web
hooks Microsoft teams we set it a
Discord option here so there are a lot
of different ways that you can get
notified if something goes wrong with
your code which is super great we have
stories of users who are on a train got
a message oh something didn't work uh
all right cool I can get in and fix it
done
all right let's look at one particular
type here we have this AWS S3 block for
storing your code
you're going to have things run out of
schedule it's going to be able to access
that code
it's as easy as in the UI if you want to
go this way
hit the add button
and put in some information
for your block block name
bucket path and if you have some some
access key information you can throw
that right in there too
okay great there you go so now you have
a colleague who maybe doesn't want to
like touch code at all and they were
able to use that form to get in some
configuration information for you so if
you have a teammate who's like nah I
just do SQL or I don't I don't want to
do any of this like maybe you can still
have give them access so you can
collaborate with them
uh and then we have blocks like this off
for notifications
so for example uh you make a little
slack notification block UI and then
boom you got some code you can use just
grab that code and go do it and get it
notified if something goes wrong or
something goes right so we have we have
a user who has
has pricing data in their code and
they're kind of monitoring pricing for
for their use case
they want to notify someone on their
sales team if the price goes up too high
above some threshold so you can do that
you can do that in your code and then
have a call not a notify method comes
for free with a notification block and
it'll notify them when that uh when that
Target was met so it's a nice way to
collaborate with people who maybe again
aren't python developers someone on the
sales team can still get that
information super easily and think about
like what it would take for you to
build that all yourself
probably some more so it's a nice free
feature right out of the gate
so there's a bunch of different block
types out there but blocks are like
totally extendable so if you want
different block types
um you can check out python libraries we
have people in the community or python
developers who've made all kinds of
different things
um just an example of some of some of
the different logos here that might
recognize for things that you could use
to extend the capabilities of blocks
uh so these are collections these are
just pip packages that you can install
and then most of them give you some
block uh superpowers so
again snowflake pvt Monte Carlo
things like that with your expectations
to you hex all kinds of possibilities
these are just some of them but if you
want even more block types
that's great
you can create your own
again these are just classes and objects
so it's not it's not hard once you have
pre-pack installed you can just import
the core block class subclassic
and you're on your way we've got a get
volume method here this is just taken
out of our Docs
it's really just a couple lines of code
to start building your own blocks
once you've made a new block you somehow
need to tell the server like that
actually exists right whether you're
using just like a local server or using
our Cloud product whatever what we want
to do somehow I have to tell it so you
can use a command from the CLI if you've
used
streamlit or flask or lots of other
things you're used to Docker whatever it
is used to saying okay I'm just use a
CLI go for it
and then boom the block shows up in the
UI something someone can input
data into so you get that that cool uh
form code first experience whatever you
want a lot of flexibility
uh and as you might expect we got like
all the helpful things docs and a
community slack with over 20 000 members
uh recipes you can use for lots of
different use cases you have blog posts
and box strings and things like that but
I want to call it we have the CLI dash
dash help here if you've ever been on a
CLI trying to use some commands like I
don't want to refer back to the docs I
don't remember how to use this uh you
can always just say dash dash help after
pretty much any command and you will get
some documentation right there in your
CLI
using Rich we're big fans of Rich uh
everyone's use that Library over perfect
but it's really nice for working with
the CLI and uh you don't have to be able
to read every little bit here but the
takeaway is uh it can help you on your
way and just do it right in
I think that's pretty cool
all right a couple benefits here of
blocks to hit
fewer errors mentioned that before you
don't have to like think about what what
am I going to use for configuration here
someone's made a block we have one wires
off the shelf that information is
available to you right away still in the
forms form Fields right some of them are
optional if they're noted that's fine
it's required it's going to be noted too
blocks are composable
so you can use different blocks together
you can throw them all together in your
code just like you you would you have
that flexibility
uh blocks are nestable
these are nesting dolls if anyone's
familiar you can put one inside another
visualization metaphor there uh so
here's two blocks we have a registry
block where we have some information
some configuration information for your
Docker registry you can then refer to
that in your Docker container and in
fact it's right there in a form field
so you can have a little drop down and
pull up any of your Docker registry
blocks that you use and they're right
there you have that information
uh and you can add new ones right out
right off the button too
so blocks are super versatile
you can have this kind of same core
concept and we talk about how we use
this in lots of different ways it's all
over the place and prefect we're even
using Anonymous kind of blocks and we
don't want to have to think about things
under the hood we're just talking about
kind of the blocks that you're going to
be making but blocks are a really
Central thing that we're using a lot in
prefect so we talk about roles with
storing code using infrastructure to run
things notifications there's a lot of
ways you can use blocks they're just
python classes
some bonus
so blacks are totally reusable this is
really cool you make it once keep your
code dry and use it a bunch of different
places
and you can even share it with other
people in your workspace this is the
most clip Arty picture I could possibly
find for sharing so I went with that
it's just just like sharing some puzzle
pieces I don't know what those things
are doing uh but you can share your code
uh you can share with blocks across your
with your colleagues right that's that's
super nice
and then blocks are extendable quote one
of my colleagues
blacks people don't need to forge
prefect to extend it like we have an
interface for you to just go hack on it
right this uh this should make life
easier faster
and better
all right probably asking yourself right
now what else should I know about
prefect glad you're asked the question
so we like to think it is a really great
option for data flow coordination this
is just prefect overall not talking
about blocks right now but it gives you
like a whole bunch of cool things right
automatic logging right out of the gate
anytime you throw a flow decorator on a
function you get retries super easily
scheduling
that's often the thing I think we've all
want something to run on a schedule at
some point in our lives
um get notifications
because again we saw those before super
cool when things don't go well or when
they do you want to get notified do that
get caching
caching is one of those things that one
of the two hard things right like naming
things and caching there's others but
those are like two that always come to
mind
off by one ears yeah okay okay there's a
if you think hard enough you can think
of other things that are hard too but
but those are a couple tricky things
um and then async I would say maybe
async sometimes is a tricky thing
especially getting started especially
maybe in Python uh there are lots of
different ways to think about it we have
Integrations with things like desk and
Ray for parallelization we have async
support currency right out the gate
so uh we have lots of options there
uh collaborative UI you've seen that and
I'll talk a little bit about our hybrid
model like we are all about security and
you keeping your code and your data on
your machines and we not touching it
right we want to have things on our
machines this helps with all kinds of
compliance issues or you for us
win-win
and we have lots of Integrations we've
seen that kind of anything in the modern
data stack you might want to use
probably have an integration for it or
if we don't real soon
and then incremental adoption is one of
those things that makes you say huh what
is it what does that really mean
um it means you can bring your own
python code
this is just a super easy start here
hello world kind of deal
I'm just gonna have a Hello function
print out something
all you have to do is add an app flow
decorator that after you've imported it
and you get automatic logging now at the
bottom right you're already starting to
like have some information stories
starting to get some value right away so
we want to make it super easy to get
started and uh then as you grow and need
more
you can learn more right we want to just
make it easy to go all the way up you
want retries
it's as easy as passing some value to
the retries parameter here in your flow
decorator so super super quick right
if you want some notifications make that
notification uh you use notifications in
we've got a couple ways you can do it
when is you can use a block or you can
just do it right in the UI again with
the notifications like here I want to
hear this flow failed or passed or
whatever it is and again you get it
through email Microsoft teams slack and
soon to be Discord it's done we just got
to get on the UI it's probably this week
all right so briefly mention prefect
cloud like okay this is great we're
using uh we can do this All ourselves
with open source but a lot of times you
don't want to deal with hassles right
you want to have kind of a hosted
managed solution uh that's prefect Cloud
we give you a free tier with lots of
good stuff like lots of you can do
everything you want to do there probably
uh but then if you're an Enterprise
company and you want to have those
Enterprise level controls we will let
you pay us so that we can fund
development of all the other good stuff
so this is kind of what the interface
looks like here whether you're using the
open source or the cloud interface
you'll get a nice usable UI
and if you're using Cloud you get a
hybrid model again where your 8 or agent
is running your code on your
infrastructure bring your own
infrastructure that's one of the things
you want to do with prefect we don't
want to be touching that code we don't
be touching
that data
so other things to know about prefect
Cloud we just passed two billion task
runs which is one of those things that
would I think take you 60 years if
you're counting the straight right like
30 years if you count to a billion uh
it's a big number right so this is
definitely being used by lots and lots
of books
I'm going to leave you uh with with kind
of one more blocks metaphor here I think
metaphors are super great for
understanding New Concepts
um I'm always trying to to make things
accessible using metaphors
um so the block and tackle
I feel like is one of those things we
don't hear a lot about these days we've
got like more powerful tools out there
but it's a pretty cool idea
um using some pulleys and ropes you get
some mechanical advantage right so it's
like a force multiplier
if you have 25 Newtons here of force and
you use this double pulley system then
you can get 100 pounds of force uh move
right 100 100 Newtons uh moved you get
that Force multiplier through mechanical
advantage
so similarly prefect blocks allow you to
do things more easily get more done
faster and I think that's the goal for
all of us here when we're coding
so I just did it one more time here why
are these blocks great
well
kind of like streamlined here right we
have this interface or
HTML so you don't have to think about it
you can use a form get that information
use it on the back end use it in your
code
hopefully resulting in fewer errors
give you some more Security benefits
when you need them at least
um and they're composable nestable
versatile reusable shareable extendable
all the holes right there
really a lot of nice things to go with
python prefix blocks
so when you're thinking about things
here and you think about your next
project think like huh is this something
I could use that would like be helpful
to me and
very curious to see how you use it
so thank you for your time I'm curious
to take any questions you have about
blocks
all right thank you so much Jeff uh any
questions
thanks for the useful information so I
have to have one question regarding
blocks you did talk about you can share
it across with the different teams is
there a way you can configure when uh a
timestamp like your blog can be
effective from this time to this time
and after that it nobody can use it or
even if they use it's not good anymore
that's really interesting idea like kind
of a lockable block after a certain
amount of time the current answer to my
investmentologists no but that sounds
like a great feature request that uh we
will put on the on the uh in the GitHub
repo because that that sounds really
cool okay that's a neat idea yeah thank
you thank you
are there questions
so something that interested me was the
move from explicit dags to the so-called
dagless so how does interdependencies
between these little blocks get managed
and how can I say
um as long as these other blocks exist I
can build you know my little say on my
flow is building a model and the
previous lows were building the features
and the data how can I make those
dependencies all work seamlessly yeah
Okay cool so this question is getting at
kind of the orchestration aspect of
prefect and so with prefect 2
um one thing we learned is that we want
to give people more flexibility and not
have to have data run in a dag Model A
directed acyclic graph model we want to
give people the ability to do looping
and things and more complex logic
um so we have a in prefect 2 there's a
radar chart that isn't just like lines
and arrows but more like a circular
chart with things going in different
directions
um and uh so to the extent uh like the
block information is is there and is
usable like you're not
people aren't generally like updating
the block information as they're going
through it so it's more just the
information being traced through through
flows
um and without going too far into it our
tests and flows uh are able to kind of
track that state information and use it
through a method of prefect futures
um so that's we can we can maybe chat
more about that that afterwards I think
but um uh the block information that's
kind of there as a configuration option
is available the whole time to any of
the flows that are running so
um it it actually doesn't require
anything special for it but good
question thank you
yeah
um so I guess since I don't know much
about prefect until this uh this talk uh
whoosh is the main use case for uh blogs
that like from you in your that you're
seeing in your day-to-day and would an
example be like embedding such a Blog in
something like a Jupiter notebook or
something like those uh or is that not
even like part of the scope of like
where would I see yeah yeah in the wild
where do you see in the world yeah it's
a great question so uh this is one of
the tricky things about blocks because
they're so versatile and all over the
place really they're used in prefect in
so many different places so um anytime
you are storing your code somewhere like
we are using a block behind the scenes
the question is do you want to go and
like explicitly say I want to put this
in my S3
um that S3 bucket and do it there and
you want to like do that
um if you don't we'll just have it
running locally on your machine and
we're like working behind the scenes but
there's blocks
it's blocks all the way down almost with
uh lots lots and lots of blocks so we
see people using them all kinds of
different places lots of people doing
notifications uh lots of people storing
code in different places lots of people
using infrastructure and all kinds of
different setups
um so so lots of places we it doesn't uh
like jump right into a Jupiter novel per
se we do have an integration with
Jupiter notebooks so you can you can use
prefect with Jupiter notebooks
um but it's something more where it'll
always be there on the UI when you want
to go check it out it's on the server
and it's visible there and then you can
use it in your code as you are are
making flows and running your code in
prefect or some of these work with
deployments very well when you're like
kind of more productionizing things you
want to say
um I want this to be something that I
can can use this kind of pull code from
S3 or something and run a Docker
container or whatever like you can
specify it there on the command line
when you're making a deployment or in
your python code
so lots lots of use cases yeah
the question okay
it seems like a block can do just about
anything
so I'm having trouble wrapping my right
a little bit around a concept of
something that can do that much why do
we call it a block and not just think of
it as like a Lambda function or
something a little bit broader
yeah it's a good question I mean that's
always a tricky thing naming things we
are at one of the tricky things here uh
and blocks are as I try I kind of try to
use a lot of different images of things
that actually were blocks right because
in the world the term block is super
flexible right it's something it's a
building block you can build other
things out of it
um and it's something that it's kind of
it's kind of a concrete term which I
think is helpful when people are like
thinking about how how it works
um because we want to differentiate it
from like something like a Lambda
function because it does have like this
front end UI aspect to it and it's got
things that a Lambda function by itself
at least isn't what I think of right
so this is it is a really hard thing I
don't know what the original like
thought was on going with the term
blocks but I think it's kind of like
General utility a lot of different ways
you can go about it
um and something you can build with so I
think there are kind of a number of
different ways that that
physical
metaphorical term does work well in the
digital space so I kind of like it but
you know I'm a biosource I've been using
it for a while but it is a tricky thing
to kind of explain and wrap our heads
around right so that's why I'm excited
to be talking about it here and trying
to really make it but I think it's a
very cool concept but also like make it
accessible to people because it's a kind
of A New Concept but thank you
question the question was what shouldn't
you do with blocks
uh that's a good question what shouldn't
it might have stumped me
um
I mean she wanted something that you
want like use the right type I guess is
maybe like is there something that's
already there like um it's nice because
you're using like Matt using the
benefits of pedantic you can do things
like have that secret string obfuscation
and stuff so if you you want to use that
I just make sure you use that under the
hood there too
um so maybe just like choices about it
using something that works well
for your use case is mostly how I would
go about that but uh it's a good
question I'll try to think of more